The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Let's look
at storyboard two.
We're going to
look in more detail
at carbohydrate
catabolism at this point.
We're eventually
going to be doing
the pathway of glycolysis, but
we have to get there first.
And it depends on
what precursors
are available to enter
the pathway of glycolysis.
One option that we'll
look at a little bit
later is to take in
glucose from the blood
by way of a glucose
carrier, and then
phosphorylate the glucose
using either hexokinase or
glucokinase.
The second option is to take
glycogen, the polymeric storage
form of glucose, and degrade it
to glucose 1-phosphate, which
will be then converted to
glucose 6-phosphate which
will enter the
pathway of glycolysis.
We're going to start with this
pathway of glycogen breakdown,
or glycogenolysis.
Panel A shows the
structure of glycogen,
which consists of glucose
monomeric units connected
by a bond between
the 1 and 4 carbons
in the alpha configuration.
Chemistry is going
to be happening
at the non-reducing end,
which is to the left.
The reducing end,
which is to the right,
is connected to a scaffolding
protein called glycogenin.
We'll come back to glycogenin
later in the course.
Let's look next at panel
B. The reaction begins
with the proteination of the red
oxygen between the terminal two
glucose moieties by a proton
on the glycogen phosphorylase
enzyme.
The intermediate product is
a resonant stabilized pair
of positively charged
species, or cations,
an oxonium ion at
the 1 prime oxygen,
and a carbocation
at the 1-carbon.
The electrophilic
carbocation is attacked
by the negatively charged
phosphate residue, which
is non-covalently associated
with glycogen phosphorylase
to form glucose 1-phosphate.
Note that the glucose
1-phosphate that forms
has the covalently attached
phosphate on the alpha,
or bottom face, as it's
drawn in the figure.
The structure of
glycogen phosphorylase
allows attack of it's
phosphate from the bottom,
giving rise to alpha isomer
only of glucose 1-phosphate.
The structure of
the phosphorylase
precludes access
of its phosphate
to the top face of
the sugar molecule,
so you get only one stereoisomer
of glucose 1-phosphate out
of this reaction.
The other product shown
at the bottom of panel C
is the glycogen chain, which
is truncated or shortened
by one glucose unit.
Now looking at the big picture,
the epinephrine molecule
produced as part of
the stress response
interacted with the cell
membrane of the muscle cell.
And that interaction
ultimately activated glycogen
phosphorylase to enable it to
degrade glycogen, the storage
form of glucose, and liberate
glucose 1-phosphate, which
is going to then find its way
into glycolysis to generate
fast energy to
enable the student
to be able to stand
up in class and avoid
the stressful situation.
I'm not going to go
through all of the details
of the chemical
reactions of glycolysis.
You can find those
in the book which
does a good job of
presenting those details.
In the first step
of glycolysis, we
see the phosphorylated
hexose, glucose 6-phosphate,
be converted by
phosphoglucoisomerase
into the furanose
fructose 6-phosphate.
The next step involves
the phosphorylation
of the fructose 6-phosphate
by phosphofructokinase 1.
ATP is the phosphate donor,
and you form fructose
1,6-bisphosphate as the product.
You'll notice that
phosphofructokinase
catalyzes one way, a
thermodynamically irreversible
reaction.
This step, like hexokinase
we talked about earlier,
are sites of regulation
of the pathway.
The word glycolysis comes from
the Greek word sugar splitting,
and we're now at the
step where the splitting
of the sugar from one
6-carbon compound into two
3-carbon compounds occurs.
The enzyme that splits the sugar
in half is called aldolase.
And, again, I advise
you to take a look
at the book to see the detail
of the chemical reaction.
Briefly, the enzyme is going to
form a proteinated Schiff base
at the number two carbon of
the fructose 1,6-bisphosphate.
That proteinated Schiff base
is going to draw electrons all
the way over from the hydroxyl
group on carbon 4 of fructose
1,6-bisphosphate.
That movement of
electrons is going
to result in cleavage
of the molecule
into two parts at the broken
line shown in the figure.
Carbons 1, 2, and
3 are going to form
DHAP, or dihydroxyacetone
phosphate,
and carbons 4, 5,
and 6 are going
to form GAP, or
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate.
GAP and DHAP are the products
of the aldolase reaction.
As an aside, this is also a
branch point in the pathway.
Dihydroxyacetone phosphate
is an opportunity
for the cell to make the
glycerol backbones of lipids
that we'll come to later.
So we see here that
glycolysis is indeed
a resource that can
be used for things
other than energy generation.
Now let's look at panel B.
Imagine that a cell is
committed to make as much energy
as it can.
For example, the
stand up, sit down
scenario we talked
about earlier.
In that case, the enzyme TIM,
or triosephosphate isomerase,
is going to interconvert
very quickly dihydroxyacetone
phosphate and
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate,
and glyceraldehyde
2-phosphate is
going to be the
molecule that progresses
along the glycolysis pathway.
In the next step of glycolysis,
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate
will be oxidized by
dehydrogenase, or GAPDH.
Again, take a look at the
mechanism in the book.
In brief, it involves attack
by a thiol residue of a GAPDH
cysteine on the aldehydic carbon
of glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate.
The product is a thiohemiacetal
which is then oxidized.
Its electrons are transferred
as hydride to NAD+ on the enzyme
to form NADH.
This is the only oxidation step
in the pathway of glycolysis.
The oxidation of the hemiacetal
produces the thioester,
and that thioester is a
very high energy compound.
The thioester is attacked by
inorganic phosphate to form
an acetylphosphate, another
high energy compound,
which is called
1,3-bisphosphoglycerate.
The acetylphosphate of
1,3-bisphosphoglycerate then
phosphorylates ADP to form ATP
in the first ATP forming step
of glycolysis.
Keep in mind that
two molecules of GAP
have been formed in the
upstream part of the pathway.
So for each molecule
of glucose, you're
getting two molecules
of ATP at this step.
The enzyme that does
this phosphorylation
is phosphoglycerate kinase.
After 1,3-bisphosphoglycerate
has lost its terminal phosphate
from the 1-carbon, it forms
the acid 3-phosphoglycerate.
As a reminder,
mutases are enzymes
that move a functional
group from one atom
to another on the same molecule.
The next enzyme in the pathway
is phosphoglycerate mutase,
which in effect moves
the phosphate from the 3
to the 2-carbon, forming
2-phosphoglycerate, which
is the next intermediate
in the glycolysis pathway.
Although it's easy to
say that the phosphate is
quote unquote "moved," that
is somewhat inaccurate.
If you look at the details
of the step in the book,
you'll see that the reaction
starts with the transfer
of a phosphate from the mutase
protein to the substrate
3-phosphoglycerate, forming an
intermediate bis-phosphorylated
product 2,3-bisphosphoglycerate.
As an aside, this is the same
powerful allosteric effector
that JoAnne described when
she taught us about how small
molecules can dramatically
reduce the affinity
of hemoglobin for oxygen. In
the case of the mutase, however,
the enzyme will take the
phosphate off of the 3-hydroxyl
of 2,3-bisphosphoglycerate
and the enzyme will
re-phosphorylate itself.
So the final product of
the phosphoglycerate mutase
reaction is 2-phosphoglycerate.
Now let's turn to
storyboard four.
In panel A, we see
the enzyme enolase,
which removes the
hydrogen from the 2-carbon
of 2-phosphoglycerate.
This is not an easy task.
The PK of that
hydrogen is about 30.
Nevertheless, the reaction
does occur and liberates water.
The product is
phosphoenolpyruvate,
usually abbreviated PEP, or PEP,
a very high energy compound.
We're now almost at the end
of the pathway of glycolysis.
And as I mentioned
earlier, one usually
looks for highly exergonic
steps near the beginnings
or ends of pathways to see
where the pathway is regulated.
Pyruvate kinase, or PK, the
last step in the pathway
is such a regulation point.
The pyruvate kinase reaction
occurs in two steps.
In the first step,
phosphoenolpyruvate
phosphorylates ADP to form ATP.
The enol product then undergoes
enol-keto tautomerization,
yielding the ketone pyruvate.
And pyruvate is the
end of the pathway.
Let's turn now to
story board five,
panel A. Let's take a
look at this pathway
from a higher altitude.
First, as I just
mentioned, the pathway
is regulated at
the top and bottom
specifically at the
hexokinase step,
the glycogen phosphorylase step,
and the pyruvate kinase step.
It's also regulated in
the middle, specifically
at the phosphofructokinase
one step.
Regulation can be
allosteric, which we
shall see as the case with PFK.
It also can be covalent.
We saw that this is the case
with glycogen phosphorylase,
or GP.
The last lecture,
we'll take a look
at regulation of these
enzymes in great detail.
As a second issue, let's
now look at the pathway
as drawn in summary form in
panel B of this storyboard.
We start with a single molecule
of the 6-carbon sugar glucose.
Hexokinase or
glucokinase will utilize
one ATP to form a
phosphorylated intermediate.
Phosphofructokinase-1 will use
a second ATP to form a doubly
phosphorylated hexose,
fructose 1,6-bisphosphate.
Bis-phosphorylated
hexose will split
into two trioses,
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate and
dihydroxyacetone phosphate.
These are inter-convertible.
The chemical species
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate
is subjected to oxidation.
Because we get two molecules
of GAP per molecule of glucose,
GAP oxidation will produce
two molecules of NADH.
In the next step,
we're going to make
two ATP's using the enzyme
phosphoglycerate kinase.
At this point,
we're ATP neutral.
We've consumed two ATP's and
we've generated two ATP's.
And lastly, the enzyme pyruvate
kinase is going to generate
an additional two ATP's.
I put those in a box, because
these are the two net ATP's
for the whole pathway.
So that's the pathway
of glycolysis.
I want to give you a little
bit of a preview of coming
attractions at this point.
What you'll notice is that the
pathway involves an oxidation
step in which we consumed two
NAD+ molecules and generated
two NADH's.
NAD+ is derived from a vitamin.
We'll only have
limited amounts of it.
We need to find a way to
regenerate the NAD+ in order
to process the next
molecule of glucose,
and we'll see that nature has
several ways to solve that
problem.
Nature actually has three
ways to regenerate NAD+.
The first we'll call
alcoholic fermentation.
The second is
homolactic fermentation,
and the third is respiration.
Alcoholic fermentation and
homolactic fermentation
occur in the absence of
oxygen. That is, anaerobically.
Respiration by definition
is an aerobic process.
Now we'll look at each of these
mechanisms of regeneration
of NAD+ in some detail, but
also, in addition to NAD+,
you're going to have to generate
a number of other products that
can be useful to the cell.
We'll see those later.
Let's look at panel C.
Under anaerobic conditions,
yeast will take pyruvate
and convert it initially
to acetaldehyde, and then reduce
the acetaldehyde to ethanol.
These are the reactions
of alcoholic fermentation.
Yeast uses an enzyme called
pyruvate decarboxylase
to process the pyruvate.
Pyruvate decarboxylase,
or PDC, has on it
a covalently attached
thiamin pyrophosphate.
Thiamin is derived
from vitamin B1.
As we go through the pyruvate
decarboxylase reactions,
at the outset I want
you to keep in mind
that PDC, pyruvate
decarboxylase,
is very similar to the front
end of the chemical reaction
series that's conducted by
an enzyme present in mammals
like us.
That enzyme complex has
pyruvate dehydrogenase,
which we'll come to a
little later when we
talk about respiration.
The thiazole ring in
TPP forms an ylide.
That means that despite the
fact that the PKA of the thiamin
pyrophosphate is
about 19, you are
able to form a carbanion at the
carbon of the thiazolium ring
system.
That carbanion attacks the
middle carbon of pyruvate,
converting it from a
ketone to an alcohol.
Now you have the thiazolium ring
system with the positive charge
beta to the carboxylate
of pyruvate.
That system readily
decarboxylates
as shown, liberating thiamin
pyrophosphate and the product,
acetaldehyde.
The next enzyme in
this small pathway
is alcohol dehydrogenase
which utilizes
NADH, which came in, in
principle, from the GAPDH
step of glycolysis.
Alcohol dehydrogenase uses
the glycolysis-derived NADH
to reduce the aldehyde
functionality of acetaldehyde
to form the product of
this pathway, ethanol.
Ethanol is an alcohol, hence
the name alcoholic fermentation.
So looking at this small
pathway in total, what you see
is that you form CO2 as
a first product, which
could be the bubbles in
a carbonated beverage
or what makes bread
rise, and form ethanol
as the other major product.
And, of course, you
get your NAD+ back,
which you can then
return to glycolysis,
specifically the GAPDH
step of glycolysis,
to enable metabolic processing
of the next molecule
of glucose.
So this is the
pathway that yeast
and other
alcohol-forming organisms
use to maintain redox
neutrality within the cell.
I'm on storyboard six, and we're
going to start with panel D.
The second general mechanism
that we're going to look
at that concerns the
regeneration of NAD+
for glycolysis is called
homolactic fermentation.
This occurs in mammals and
in lactic acid bacteria.
And like alcoholic
fermentation, it
is also a process that
occurs anaerobically.
That is, in the
absence of oxygen.
As you can see,
pyruvate is a keto acid,
and the ketone at the number 2
carbon can be easily reduced.
In this case, NADH will
transfer hydride to the ketone
in order to reduce it
to the alcohol lactate.
The net reaction here involves
consumption of one NADH
and the production of one NAD+.
And this NAD+ of course, can go
back and be utilized to enable
oxidation of the next molecule
of glucose passing through
the glycolytic pathway.
When a mammal is
running hard, this
is the pathway by
which we achieve redox
neutrality and glycolysis.
When we exercise
intensely, lactate
is produced in excess to keep
the glycolytic pathway active.
The lactate causes the
blood pH to go down.
That is, the blood becomes more
acidic because lactic acid has
a low PKA.
I also want to point out that
this anaerobic pathway is also
the basis for production
of lactate by lactic acid
bacteria, which is critical to
the manufacturing of yogurt.
Let's look now at panel E. The
third pathway to regenerate
NAD+ for glycolysis
is respiration.
We're going to be going through
respiration in some detail
later, but right now
I'm going to give you
a very high level view of it.
In the way of an introduction,
the mitochondrial intermembrane
is very well equipped to be
able to transport electrons.
Those electrons
will travel along
in an electron transport chain
to oxygen, reducing the oxygen
we breathe into water.
This is a highly energy
generating process,
and the energy that's generated
is part of the driving
force for the synthesis of ATP.
The details of how a respiring
organism generates ATP
is covered later.
For right now, however, let's
just say that the mitochondrial
membrane oxidizes NADH to
regenerate the NAD+ needed
to sustain glycolysis.
And, again, we'll
see the details
of how this happens later.
Later, I'll also cover the
ways that redox neutrality is
maintained in a mammalian cell.
In brief, NAD+ is generated
from NADH in aerobes by a series
of reactions that I call
quote unquote "the shuttles,"
which will be covered
in section 12.
Before we go on, let me give you
a little recap of where we are.
We've seen that there are a
couple of optional beginnings
for glycolysis.
It can begin with intake
of glucose from the blood,
or it can begin with the
breakdown of glycogen
by glycogenolysis.
The formal pathway takes glucose
as glucose 6-phosphate down
to pyruvate.
We get a total of two
ATP's in that process,
and we produce two NADH's.
Now, however, we've got to have
a way to be able to regenerate
our NAD+ from those NADH's
in order to be able to make
the pathway ready to process
the next molecule of glucose.
Accordingly, nature developed
three endings to the pathway
that result in the
regeneration of NAD+.
These endings are
alcoholic fermentation,
homolactic fermentation,
and respiration.
Looking at that picture in
panel E once again, in us,
respiration happens
in the mitochondria
and primarily in the
mitochondrial intermembrane
and in the jelly-like
mitochondrial matrix.
Pyruvate generated
in the cytoplasm--
that's the compartment
where glycolysis occurs--
goes through the porous outer
membrane of the mitochondria.
Then, the pyruvate encounters
the membrane-bound pyruvate
dehydrogenase complex,
which is our next topic.
In bacteria, which are in
many ways like mitochondria,
respiration happens in
the cellular membrane
and in the cell's cytoplasm.
Let's take a look at panel
A of storyboard seven.
We're about to start our
discussion of respiration,
which is the
oxidative metabolism
of all metabolic fuels via the
common intermediate acetyl CoA.
In mammals, as I
said earlier, these
are mitochondrial reactions.
At the outset, I also
want to point out
that we have seen
that carbohydrates
can be metabolized either
anaerobically or aerobically.
As we'll see when we use
lipids as our metabolic fuels,
they can only be
metabolized aerobically.
Lipids break down to
acetyl CoA, which is then
oxidized by the TCA cycle.
Let's take a look
at panel B. When
we talked about alcoholic
fermentation earlier,
I said that yeast have a
pyruvate decarboxylase complex,
and I said that the reactions
of the pyruvate decarboxylase
complex are very similar to
the reactions in the early part
of the pyruvate
dehydrogenase reaction, which
is a little bit more complex.
Pyruvate dehydrogenase has three
activities, E1, E2, and E3.
As with pyruvate
decarboxylase, E1
has a thiamine pyrophosphate
unit, TPP, and ylide on the TPP
attacks the middle
carbon of the pyruvate.
Specifically, it's
ketone carbon.
At this point,
you're going to want
to take a look at detailed
notes that I've provided
as supplemental material.
This supplemental
material will be
referred to as slide one,
slide two, and so on.
Looking at slide one, you
can see that decarboxylation
happens exactly
the same way that I
described for the pyruvate
decarboxylase system.
Now take a look at
slides two through six.
In the case of PDH,
pyruvate dehydrogenase,
unlike the situation with
PDC, pyruvate decarboxylase,
restructuring of the
carboxyethyl group
is going to result in the
formation of our carbanion
that's going to attack the
disulfide of lipoic acid.
Looking at slide seven,
you'll see the conversion
of the hydroxyethyl to
a keto functionality
jettisons the TPP, resulting
in a thioester in which there
is an acyl group
connected to lipoic acid.
At this point, the
thiol of coenzyme A
attacks the keto oxygen
of the thioester,
producing acetyl
CoA, which is going
to become a very important
molecule as we move ahead.
The second product is
reduced lipoic acid.
Technically, the formation
of reduced lipoic acid
is the oxidation step of
the pyruvate dehydrogenase
reaction.
The decarboxylation
step that happened
a few steps earlier is
basically the production of CO2
that we eventually will
breathe out when we exhale.
Now let's look at slide eight.
The reducing equivalents
on the E2 subunits
present as reduced
lipoic acid will
move across the E2 subunit
toward the E3 subunit.
The E3 subunit has an
oxidized disulfide bond on it,
which was created by
the connection of two
cysteines on the protein.
That oxidized disulfide
is then reduced
by transfer of the
reducing equivalents
from the reduced lipoic
acid to the disulfide.
And then finally, the
reducing equivalents
are passed from the reduced
disulfide to FAD to form FADH2.
That FADH2 passes along its
reducing equivalents to NAD+
forming NADH.
This NADH is soluble and will
move to its next location.
Specifically, this NADH will
return to the mitochondrial
membrane-- actually to another
place in the mitochondrial
membrane--
an enzyme called complex one,
and be oxidized in the electron
transport chain.
Overall, one pyruvate
enters the PDH complex.
We lose its carboxylate as CO2.
We generate from pyruvate's
residue an acetyl coenzyme A.
And at the very
end, we get an NADH,
which will then go on to the
electron transport complex
to be oxidized.
The formation of NAD+,
as I mentioned above,
is critical to allow
further oxidation of reduce.
That is, energy rich
molecule such as glucose.